Okay, we will get started.
Now we're going to start the systems
portion of the class. So we've been
doing a bunch of neural network stuff
for the last two lectures and now we're
going to start getting into GPUs,
parallelization
and inference. And systems I think is
going to be I think part of the stack
that is most reasonable in a way in the
sense that you can like reason through
all the pieces
and there'll be kind of like logical
steps that you can go through to get the
result. So it's very different and
satisfying. But when you first start
interacting with GPUs, it will feel a
little bit like both magic and like a
very strange device that you're
interacting with. I don't really know
as a kind of class survey, how many of
you have taken like a GPU programming
class of any kind?
Okay, so this is this is pretty good.
Like that's like a fourth, maybe a
little bit less.
But I think when you first interact with
these things, it's actually a little bit
of magic. So it's good to understand. Um
And I think, you know,
deep neural networks feel like magic but
also GPUs can too. Sometimes people will
show you plots like this.
Part of this lecture, I think my promise
to you is that by the end of this
lecture you will understand what this
plot is or why this plot looks the way
it does. And this is, you know, how much
throughput you're getting on a matrix
multiply where the x-axis is your
dimension. And you might think, well,
you know, maybe bigger matrix multiplies
are always more throughput cuz you have
more work to do. Well, you've got all
these kind of crazy patterns happening
where like at certain sizes your map
moles are much much slower than others.
Why? You know, you'll need to understand
that.
You also need to understand some basics
of how to sort of mentally think about a
GPU in order to build fast algorithms.
And even if you're not a systems person,
I think probably not all of you or even
a majority of you are systems people,
but if you're thinking about
architectures or just generally
reasoning about these things, you kind
of need to understand the hardware model
of how your, you know, model is going to
execute in order to make an effective
model, right? Thinking back to uh
Percy's initial lecture, right? Big part
of scaling is making sure you use your
resources effectively. And without
understanding your systems, you will
never be efficient at using your
resources.
Um and, you know,
I am not a systems person, surprise. Um
and so before I start, I want to, you
know, make sure to point you towards
resources that I think are very good and
very useful and that I used um in making
this lecture. Um Horace He has, you
know, really incredible blogs and
explainers of, you know, how GPUs work.
There's an enthusiast group CUDA mode um
that loves to talk about um
uh GPUs and CUDA kernels and so on. Um
and there's a TPU and now what?
>> They're GPU mode now. They changed their
name.
>> Okay, fine. GPU mode. Um
and uh the TPU book, but now it's also a
GPU book by the Google folks. Actually,
this is a really incredible resource. So
if you're really excited or interested
by any of the stuff I talk about today,
I would strongly encourage you to look
at uh that book. And they also have
exercises um that you can work through
and your assignment will have things
that look a little bit like those
exercises so you can get a little bit of
a preview of what we will um send you to
later.
Great.
Okay. So this lecture is going to be in
three parts. The first part is really, I
would say, just like broad introductory
material on GPUs. This is going to be
just the hardware model, just how the
programming of the GPU kind of works. Um
because GPU is kind of a foreign device
and I want you to understand
philosophically how they're different
from CPUs.
Um then once you do that, we're going to
talk about um I think six different
tricks, um important tricks, to get a
GPU to go fast. These are just kind of
building blocks of how you can start to,
you know, manipulate your code um in
order to make it run efficiently on a
GPU. And then finding the last part
where we put all of this together is
going to be we're going to walk through
flash attention, and this will be kind
of our victory lap. We will say
actually, at this point we understand
everything we need in order to, you
know, reinvent our own flash attention
and to understand all the different
components, right? So that's going to be
kind of the the goal that we're going to
be building towards by the end of
lecture.
Okay. So we haven't gone to scaling yet,
but you know, from Percy's introductory
lecture or you know, just generally
following language modeling, you know,
we kind of know that if we have more
compute on hand, we can get, you know,
better language models, right? This is
kind of the currency by which we
operate. So if we have faster hardware,
or if we have better utilization, or you
know, we have more chips, and then we
have improved parallelization, all of
these can drive progress, right?
And so in some sense, the game for the
last few years has been how can we bring
more compute to bear in training models?
And I guess in the last year or so,
how can we bring more compute to bear in
the inference of these models, right? So
compute is just extremely important and
systems is part of that.
So if we were talking about this in the
'90s, I think the things that we would
be focusing on is clock speed, right? We
would be saying things like, well, you
know, how we make computers go fast is
we have a CPU that executes instructions
serially, and we make those instructions
go faster and faster, right? I mean,
this type of scaling, where transistors
got smaller and clock speeds got faster,
you know, called Dennard scaling,
held quite well for for a while, really
the 2000s was about when this kind of
scaling tapped out.
And one sort of interesting side note,
right? The number of transistors, of
course, has continued to go up, but
making transistors smaller does not
necessarily mean that your transistors
go faster, right? They don't move at a
faster clock speed. There's fundamental
physical reasons why, you know, you
don't actually continue to get benefits
of smaller and smaller transistors at a
certain point.
So this old approach of like making your
clocks faster, making instructions
execute faster is not going to work,
right? So, how do we, you know, get LLMs
to continue to scale in this world where
we can't just make things faster in sort
of this frequency sense?
Right? And that's, you know, where the
GPU shows up in sort of parallel scaling
in general, right? Um Percy's going to
talk about sort of more advanced topics
next lecture, but after that's going to
be parallelism, right? Parallelism and
GPUs are both kind of part of the same
paradigm. Instead of making things go
faster serially, with your your clock
going faster and faster and faster,
instead you're going to, you know, scale
horizontally, right? Have more things
executing your your instructions in
parallel. And so, this is kind of the
story of GPUs. This one slide really, I
think, or one picture, summarizes, you
know, the state of parallel scaling,
which is, you know, in the early days
of, you know, K20s and M40s, you had,
you know, respectable, but somewhat
pitiful by today's standards, flops. And
all of a sudden, around P100s and V100s,
this curve takes off, and you get super
exponential scaling in the amount of
floating-point operations that you can
do, uh sort of year-by-year, right? This
is kind of a remarkable plot in the
amount of compute that we can bring to
bear.
Um and so, you know, GPU scaling has
really driven almost all of the compute
scaling that we've seen. Um and we'll
talk about all of the different
components that we have here. Um you
know, I'll highlight them here just to
put them into your head. You know, at at
the V100 era, in 2017, we start getting
Tensor Cores. That's one of the big
hardware uh innovations. And then in the
in the next few years, we're seeing, you
know, uh
structured sparsity and FPA and all
these sort of lower number formats also
driving our our flops forward. And we're
going to see uh sort of what that means
in detail uh in a little bit.
So, how is a GPU different from a CPU?
Those that have, you know, interacted
with a GPU already know this. We'll move
on to a more advanced things in a
minute. But for the rest of you, I think
it's very important to understand the
the model, like the philosophy in some
sense, of how they're different. So, a
CPU is designed for quick serial
execution, where you have sort of
complex branching logic, complex
conditionals, complex control flows.
Because of this, a CPU, generally
speaking, has really big control units,
and it has a few ALUs that can do sort
of mathematical or other operations. But
this is meant to run very quickly,
right? So, you want to go as fast as
possible and sort of have low latency.
The time between when you get an
instruction and when you complete it
should be very, very short, right?
That's kind of the general CPU design
philosophy.
In contrast, the GPU is really about
throughput, right? And, you know, the
the plot on the right, I think, is a
great pictorial illustration of the when
you change these philosophies, what you
end up getting. So, in a GPU, maybe you
dispatch a task, it takes a long time
for it to finish, right? It might be
that you process a task and then you
stop and then you go work on another
task, and then you go back and work on
another task. But in general, right,
even though your tasks don't finish
quickly,
you know, you're getting large aggregate
throughput across all of your tasks. And
what enables this is having tons and
tons of lightweight cores, right? So, a
GPU has hundreds and hundreds of sort of
compute units that are sort of packed
into a chip, and all of these can
execute in parallel, right? So, this is
a very different mode of programming and
thinking compared to a CPU.
Okay?
Um and I want to demystify what a GPU
is. I don't want you to think of it as
like a, you know, set of pieces of text
on Nvidia as am I. I want you to like be
able to sort of visualize what the
hardware is of a GPU. Um I think this
picture is, I think, usually used as a
pictorial illustration of what a GPU is.
I think this is a great logical picture
of what's happening inside of a GPU. So,
a GPU, um
the basic unit of a GPU is a SM, a
streaming multiprocessor.
And a streaming multiprocessor is kind
of like a core. It's its own independent
compute unit that has, you know, sub
components that it can use uh to
accelerate its computation and it has
access to certain kinds of memories that
it can connect to.
Right? So, each SM, you know, building
on this idea of parallelism, it's not a
single sort of compute unit has
streaming processors inside of it that
can then execute different threads in
parallel. But a SM is kind of the the
discrete compute unit. We'll see why uh
later when I get to the programming
model. Um each SM you can think of as
kind of a core almost. Um and GPUs have
tons of SMs. Like a A100 will have 128
SMs. Each of these can be independently
programmed and they can independently
execute different jobs. And they have
access to to sort of global memory
outside of it.
Um and the other thing that we will see
that's kind of the the sort of compute
story of a GPU. Um but we will see
throughout this lecture that a really,
really important part of this story is
not just the compute part, but the
memory part, right? Modern sort of
hardware and LM optimization is really
defined by the memory. And so, we need
to understand
what the memories are and where they
live. So, when we talk about memory,
there's different kinds. Um
there's different levels of caches that
are connected to a GPU. There are
registers which are even more limited
and even faster. And then you have
global or high bandwidth memory. Um and
as you can kind of see from this table,
this is a a benchmarking that's that
some folks did of uh I think this was a
A100 uh latencies. You know, the L1 and
shared memory, these are very fast,
right? In something like 20 to 30
cycles, you can kind of read and get
data from them. If you're hitting the L2
cache, much slower. And if you're
hitting global memory, you know, that's
10 times slower than the L1 cache. This
is a big difference in your speed,
right? And this global memory is kind of
what you normally think of as a, you
know, high-level programmer as a GPU
memory, right? When a H200 tells you
I've got 144 gigs of memory, you're
talking about global memory, right?
You're not talking about shared or L1
cache.
Now, physically, where do these things
live? Well, global memory, you know,
usually are these kind of memory chips
that live outside of your sort of
compute unit, whereas L2 and L1 cache,
they kind of live physically in the chip
itself, right? So, this is kind of the
the picture of a GPU chip.
Um and you see all these SMs, these
green blocks are SMs. Um and you see L2
right here and the L1 is inside of each
of us SMs, right? So, so they're
physically much closer to the compute
units, that's why their latency is so
much better, right?
Um
And you might say, "Okay, then if shared
memory is so nice, why don't you build a
whole chip out of shared memory?" Um
it's much more expensive, hundreds of
times. It's also much more power hungry,
right? From the way that these memories
are built. Um and so, this is the reason
why if you're building a practical
accelerator, often you don't want to
just, you know, have a giant amount of
shared memory, you want to have the sort
of hierarchy of memory, right? And use
it effectively.
Um I think uh Grok, right? Which was
recently acquired by Nvidia, was a
design where you just had these giant
amounts of SRAM, right? And for certain
workloads like inference, this is very
helpful. Um but still, for most
accelerators, you're going to have this
hierarchy that you're going to have
really have to respect uh in order to
make anything run fast.
Yes.
>> So, what's the difference between the
shared memory and the L1 cache?
>> Uh yeah. So, the the shared memory is,
you know, and the L1 cache, I guess,
kind of operate differently. The cache
is really just a cache thing that that
is storing recently accessed data
elements. Shared memory is a
programmable element that you'll
actually interact with, that you can
like put things in and out of.
Okay, cool.
Right, so that's the memory story and
keep that in mind because it's going to
keep coming back, the memory hierarchy.
That's It's important object.
Now, okay, we have the hardware mental
model in place and now we're going to
start talking about the software and
programming model of a GPU.
Um so, there's three different important
players that live in the execution model
of a GPU. Um so, there's a thread and if
you're familiar with multi um uh
parallel programming of any kind, you
know what a thread is, right? A thread
is a sort of lightweight thing that's
running in parallel and doing some work,
right? Um in a GPU, an important thing
about the threads is they follow the
SIMT model, which means that all of the
threads that you have are executing the
same exact instructions, right? Um
they're going to have different inputs,
which means that the threads can
actually do separate useful work, but
the instructions they execute have to
all be the same, right? And this is this
has important implications for both the
efficiency of your code as well as the
programming model, right? If the threads
can do all sorts of different stuff, it
becomes a very hard to program, right?
GPUs are this trade-off between
programmability um and efficiency.
Now, a block is a group of threads and
the reason why a block is a relevant
object is that a block is guaranteed to
run on a single SM. And remember, an SM
has a shared memory, and so you can
think of a thread as doing work in
parallel. Blocks have a access to a
shared pool of memory. That will become
very important later when we talk about
this idea called tiling, where these
blocks are going to be reusing the same
pieces of memory.
Finally, um a warp is essentially kind
of the scheduling unit of um what is
happening inside the GPU. Threads are
going to execute in groups of 32
consecutively numbered threads. That is
a warp, right? This decreases the
overhead of a scheduler deciding which
threads to run. But essentially, these
are kind of the important three
terminology items for a GPU. I might say
something like, "Oh, you know, we're
going to have different warps
executing." That's what I mean here.
That's a basic unit of 32 threads that
execute together.
Yes.
>> Uh you mentioned like all threads
execute the same instructions. So, is it
all threads in a block or all threads in
a warp?
>> All threads in a warp are going to be
executing. Um
Cool.
Yeah.
>> So, then the scheduler decides which
warp the next instruction goes to?
>> That's right. Or or sorry, the scheduler
decides which warp is going to be
executing next.
In in a warp assignment and so on. Yeah.
Cool.
Okay. Um and so in the memory model of a
GPU, um you know, device code can read
from registers. Registers are some some
of the fastest and most local uh items.
This might be storing things like memory
addresses of, you know, where you might
need to your arrays start and end.
That's a place where you might store
things in registers. Um then you've got
local memory. This is local to within
your your single SM. You've got shared
memory that can be accessed sort of
within your block. So, if you have
something you want to transfer across
threads, or you want to have information
that is going to be reused across
threads, those are going to live in
shared memory. You can of course then
read out or sorry, read from global
memory, right? The the DRAM that's far
away, um as long as you're willing to
pay sort of the latency hit of waiting
for data to come to you from global
memory. Um and there's also sort of
constant memory, which I don't think
I've seen very much used in in various
programming things, um that you can use
as well.
Now, you can even sort of transfer to
and back from host memory, right? When I
say host memory, that means sort of CPU
memory that lives on the machine. Um you
can do this if you need to offload
beyond the size of your GPU. This is
kind of the set of things that you can
do um in your memory, right?
And and really the key thing, the most
important part of this this uh sort of
memory model is that as soon as you go
outside of your shared memory, things
are going to be slow. So, grouping the
blocks to sort of decrease the amount of
global memory reads is going to be the
name of the game throughout this
lecture.
Okay.
Now, I'm going to talk for two slides
two slides about TPUs.
Um the majority of this lecture is about
GPUs mainly because I think, you know,
if you all go out and you, you know,
write your code and you build your
models, it's probably going to be on
GPUs for most of you. Um but I think it
is very important that we talk about
TPUs both because I think TPUs are cool
and becoming more popular, but also
because TPUs are kind of like the
alternative evolution of GPUs and you
can kind of see what's the same, what's
not. Um it's very interesting to see uh
how TPUs work as well, right? So,
actually what's very interesting is that
TPUs are very similar to GPUs at a high
level. This is kind of convergent
evolution. If you want to build a
energy-efficient accelerator that does
machine learning, you kind of end up at
the same place.
Um so, the core mental difference
between a TPU and a GPU that you should
kind of keep in mind is that TPUs are in
some sense simpler. They're more
optimized for the machine learning
workload. Um they have lighter weight
control units and they have much bigger
matrix multiply units. Um
and so, you know, they have the same
basic structure that I'll talk about for
um for Sorry, for GPUs. Well, they will
have a specialized circuit to multiply
matrices. They will have components that
can do parallel vector operations and
they will have, you know, some control
system. They have a very similar-looking
memory structure where they have slow
memory which is called high bandwidth
memory. And then they have an even
faster local memory called S-man or
shared memory, right?
So, this looks very, very similar to the
architecture of a GPU. Really, the
difference is in is in how these things
are sized and the flexibility of these
operations. Um
and I would say, oh, and the main
difference that I won't get into today
is the networking for these
accelerators. So, if you're thinking
about what is the big difference between
a TPU and a GPU, actually the biggest
differences come in networking, not in
the individual chips. Because really the
chips, you know, they live to just
multiply matrices.
Um, and this is from the Jax book, you
know, which is a really lovely resource.
Um, but they have these two tables. They
have a section on GPUs where they
describe how to essentially map GPU
ideas to TPU ideas. And whatever I say
today about what's on the left here, you
know, you can map directly to the TPU.
But the important thing, you know, at
this point in the lecture to notice is
that for every sort of concept in the
GPU, there's a corresponding concept in
the TPU. And this, you know, mapping is
actually pretty precise. Like a tensor
core in a GPU, which is the matrix
multiply unit, corresponds almost
exactly to an MXU, which is a matrix
multiply unit in the tensor core. And if
we're getting into really needy-greedy
details, they actually use the same
underlying, you know, like circuitry,
right? They're both uh, what's called a
systolic array, which kind of streams
data in and out to to do a matrix
multiply. So, the architecture is very
similar. Now, how are they Oh, sorry,
yes.
>> Do you know like what a typical systolic
array size is on a GPU versus TPU?
>> Ooh,
uh, I do not know that off off my head.
I'm sorry. I'll have to look that up.
Yes.
Okay.
Um,
so the main difference, um, between
these two is the number of different
units that we have.
Um, so if we look at Oh, actually I'll
I'll mention one very, very confusing
thing before before I move on. Sorry.
Uh, TPUs call their streaming
multiprocessors tensor cores. GPUs call
their matrix multiply units tensor
cores. They are named exactly the same
thing. So, you will have to disambiguate
them based on context. Uh, if someone
says tensor core for a TPU, that means a
processor. If someone says tensor core
for a GPU, they mean a matrix multiply
unit.
Um, so if you look at a GPU, uh, a
typical GPU like a H100 might have
something like 132
uh, streaming multiprocessors. That's a
lot of processors. Um, a TPU will only
have two units, right? There's only two
separate units running in parallel. Now,
uh,
the GPU, if we just look at the matrix
multiply units, will have 528 matrix
multiply units, whereas a TPU will have
just eight, right? And these are, you
know, roughly scaled to be comparable
looking objects.
Why is it that it's this way? Well, the
TPU is relying on much bigger, smaller
numbers of matrix multiply units,
whereas the GPU is relying on smaller,
but much more numerous matrix multiply
units. And you can kind of imagine that
if you have a small number of many
matrix multiply units, it's going to
give you more flexibility. You can
program them to do this and that.
Whereas a TPU, you're locked in to big,
big matrix multiplies, right? And so,
there was a funny situation in a recent
paper that I wrote where, you know, we
did a batch size sweep and it goes all
the way down to 64 and it stops at 64.
Why is that? Because the tensor core
refuses to accept anything smaller than
a 64-dimensional input there, right? It
It has to be big matrix multiplies.
So, this is the main difference, but as
you can see, GPUs and TPUs share a lot
of similarities. They rely on a memory
hierarchy between fast memory and slow
memory, and they have a matrix multiply
unit. And because of that, the core
concepts that I'm teaching you today is
going to transfer over between GPU and
TPU, right? The the basic ideas are
always going to be the same for that
reason. And this is really convergent
evolution. There are only so many ways
to sort of cost-effectively allocate
memory, and there's only so many ways to
multiply matrix very fast, right?
There's some design decisions that are
different, but otherwise you end up at
the same place.
Okay. Cool. So, that's TPUs.
And right. Good.
And GPUs I think have been enormously
successful because it allows for, you
know, easy scalability for things like
matrix multiplies. If you want more
throughput, you just keep adding SMs,
right? As long as your memory bandwidth
can handle the SMs,
you get more and more throughput. The
programming is, you know, something we
don't think about, but it's deceptively
easy, right? If you were to try to
write, you know, lower-level machine
code-looking stuff like PTX, um it's
actually doable because it's all SIMD,
right? It's not like you're programming
every single thread, you know, you're
saying, "Okay, here are my instructions,
here are my inputs, now run them on all
of my inputs, right?" It's something
that maybe you all are already familiar
with with things like applying uh
applying or using functional
programming.
Finally, um I haven't talked much about
threads, but whenever you're doing GPU
programming, these threads are always
very lightweight. They can be stopped,
started at any time. The scheduler can
decide that, "Okay, I have another warp
that's, you know, better to run, so I'm
going to stop you and start this one."
Um and it's very sort of quick to sort
of swap in these jobs. That allows for
much higher throughput if certain jobs
are stalled or have some property that's
lowering throughput.
Okay. So, that's the benefit of GPUs,
you know, as a hardware model. It's been
enormously successful.
Um and I think even in the early days,
before Tensor Cores sort of were
implemented, you know, people realized
that, you know, commodity graphics
hardware, this massive parallelism,
would be very effective for, you know,
scientific computing. Um so, you know,
this is one of the original papers on
using graphics hardware for fast matrix
multiplies. Um and this is a really,
really cool sort of hacker work. You
know, people figured out, "Well, we have
these shaders that are implemented, but
we can program specific shaders that
will actually give us sort of matrix
multiplies." And different rendering
settings actually give us faster matrix
multiplies. And that's that's just sort
of really cool computer science things
you can do. But nowadays, you do not
have to do this. You do not have to
manually program your GPUs to do matrix
multiplies, because as of the V100, um
Nvidia decided, you know, here is a
piece of hardware that will do your
matrix multiplies for you. Um and once
that hardware sort of existed, matmuls
became the sort of one privileged
operation in machine learning, right?
So, at this point, there's a gigantic
gap in sort of the throughput that
you're going to get between sort of
parallelizable but non matrix multiply
operations versus amount of
[clears throat] operations you can do in
a matrix multiply, right? So, this is
one of the reasons why sort of any near
future machine learning architecture
that we see that scales with compute is
going to have a matrix multiply in it,
right? Because this is the the one way
that you can really effectively get a
lot of compute throughput.
Um more than 10 times faster than
any other floating point operation that
you can do
uh in a GPU.
Okay.
And then um the last sort of hardware
thing that I'll end with, I think this
is the last slide of this section, um is
that different components of the GPU are
scaling at different rates over time.
Um we know that the GPUs are getting
faster and faster. This is just like a
thing, right? As well as CPUs, you know,
uh overall compute throughput is getting
faster and faster. So, that's the gray
line, right? That's pretty fast. We're
getting faster and faster improvements
in the total floating point operations.
Um green is our memory bandwidth. This
is how fast we can transfer data. That's
growing comparatively slowly. Blue is
parallelism. This is how fast we can
connect different GPU devices. That's
also going very slowly. And what does
this mean? This means that if you're out
here, kind of in the early days of GPU
programming, probably you weren't
thinking much about memory because you
were you your compute wasn't that much
faster than your memory transfer. But
now, as we go more and more to the right
of this plot, we're going to see a
bigger and bigger gap between compute
and memory, and that's why a lot of the
optimization I'm talking about today are
memory optimizations, right? As we go
further to the right, we're going to see
memory and communication bottlenecks
more and more, and so it's going to take
more and more work to fully utilize the
hardware that we have.
Okay.
So, that was our sort of very basic
overview of GPUs. I can't possibly, you
know, give you a 20-minute lecture that
fully helps you understand what the GPU
hardware is, but hopefully you have a
flavor, right? The mental model should
be GPUs are massively, massively
parallel. They execute instructions all
at the same time. Um compute scales
really fast, really, really fast, and
even faster than memory, which means
memory is really important. And because
memory is important, everything we do
has to respect the memory hierarchy,
right? As much stuff that we do goes
into shared memory and not global
memory, right? So, this is kind of
hopefully your understanding of GPUs,
and if you have this understanding, at
least you'll you'll understand uh all
the basics necessary to to uh
internalize the next part uh of this
lecture.
Okay, I can pause for a moment here in
case people have hardware questions or
anything else before I move on to the
next part.
Yes.
>> So, before the V100s, there was no
matrix multiply unit like
>> Yeah, yeah, there was no tensor core
that like specialized to a matmul. Yeah,
the tensor core is a V100 addition.
Before that, you would be programming
manually. Of course, you have so many
SMs and so many like ALUs that you can
still do quite good throughput, but, you
know, a specialized circuit for matrix
multiply really, you know, changes the
game for that.
Oh, yeah, back there.
>> What is the difference between the
shared memory and the L1 cache?
>> Uh the cache just operates on its own.
Like, you don't get to control the L1
cache.
>> Is L2 slower than L1 just because of the
physical distance, or does it also
differ some other way?
>> Yeah, I mean, physical distance is a big
part of it. I mean, they are, if I
believe
if I remember right, they're both SRAM.
Like, that's one of the reasons why
global memory is much slower. But, the
physical distance and the interconnects
that are used are the reasons why it's
slower.
Yeah, this is not inherent, by the way.
Um one additional side thing is that the
the equivalent to L2 cache in TPUs is
much faster um because they make
different design tradeoffs on silicon to
to enable that. That's one of their
selling points. Yes.
>> If this is compute-memory and the keeps
growing, do you think that affects the
way future chips will be laid out? Like
>> Yeah, or or or maybe the future chip
kind of budget splits.
Um one of the things that I really
didn't want to talk about, but now you
forced me to, is kind of the inference
landscape for hardware is actually even
more crazy. Um so one of the things that
people started doing, I think last year,
was something called prefill
uh decode disaggregation, where the
prefill part, which is very heavy matrix
multiplies, is one chip, and then the
decode part for your for your inference,
which is more memory bandwidth limited,
is another chip, right? Um and some of
the models, I think this was uh step one
three, uh which is a Chinese open source
model, even has a thing where they like
try to disaggregate different layers. So
an attention will go to one chip
optimized for one thing, or one
accelerator, and then MLPs will go to a
different accelerator, right? Um and so
you're starting to see like if this gap
grows, any sort of clever tricks to, you
know, utilize your very precious fast
memory becomes very valuable, and you
start to see this very heavily in
inference, which is even more memory
bound than training. Yeah. Cool.
Oh, yeah.
>> How many warps
How many warps are in a block?
>> Uh do I know that? I don't think I know
that off the top of my head. I think
it's also hardware dependent.
Okay, good. Um
Okay, so the second part of this lecture
is now you all have a general sense of
what a GPU is and how it works. Now we
are going to talk about all of the basic
tricks to make uh workloads fast on a
GPU. These are kind of basic components
that you can kind of put together to
make things fast. And to keep us kind of
motivated, um
one of my goals by the end of this
section is to explain this plot to you,
right? So this plot, as I said before,
has a very simple picture. It's the size
of the matrix, a square matrix that I'm
multiplying on multiplying two square
matrices. Um and this Y axis is how many
items I'm processing per second. So,
this is a throughput, right?
Um, as I'm going to the right, in
general, throughput is going up because
I have bigger matrices, I have more work
to do. And so, you know, if I have a lot
more work, I can keep my hardware more
utilized, right? But, there's all sorts
of strange patterns here. And we kind of
want to understand why are there strange
patterns here? Why and how can we be at
the very top of that curve rather than
the bottom, right? So, that's what I'm
going to be talking about in the second
part.
Okay.
And, you know, Percy already mentioned
this. This is the roofline model. But,
the plot I showed before looks a little
bit like this classic roofline model,
right? This looks like there's a
diagonal part and then a flat part,
right? And this is what we expect,
right? The roofline model says, up until
a certain point, we will be memory
limited, right? We're memory limited, so
no matter how much, you know, compute
you give me, um, my sort of throughput
is not going to go up. Um, at some point
you have enough work per unit, uh, sort
of uh, memory movement that I can keep
sort of my compute units completely
saturated. And past that point, having
bigger and bigger sort of units of work
does not help me anymore, right? No
matter how much, sort of, extra work you
give me, that doesn't help because, you
know, I've fully saturated my matrix
multiply units. So, this is what we
expect out of the classic roofline model
where, you know, as we sort of have
faster memory, we can kind of push this
upwards, but there's a memory bound
region which is diagonal, and then a
compute bound region which is flat,
right? This is kind of what we expect.
Now, if you want to make sure that your
code runs efficiently on a GPU, really
what you need to do is you need to be on
this flat part, right? As soon as we
have this flat part, there's nothing
else to do, we're at maximum throughput,
right? So, we want to prevent ourselves
from being in this diagonal part, which
means we want to increase the
operational intensity. The amount of
computation we do per memory read needs
to be high enough. So, that's what we
need to do. And there's six different
tricks that we will talk about.
Actually, some of these are are not sort
of memory tricks, the first one only.
There are six different tricks that are
maybe necessary to understand to make
GPUs go fast. The first one's a little
bit different in flavor, but then the
rest of them will have this flavor of
trying to minimize memory movement as
much as possible.
The first one is kind of a GPU specific
thing and it relates to one of the
things I said before, um the SIMD model.
So, in a GPU, every thread is executing
the same thing. Now, what happens if you
write a if statement on a piece of code
that executes on a GPU, right? On a CPU,
it's quite clear what happens. On a CPU,
you know, you will either pick one
branch or the other, you will execute
that branch, and you will move on with
your life, right? In a GPU, um you will
do something actually quite different
and slightly counterintuitive. Um every
thread has to execute the same
instruction. So, actually every thread
will kind of execute both the if and the
else, but if you're not part of the if
branch, you will just mask out that
computation, you'll just sit idle,
right? And so, whenever you have a
conditional, your mental model for the
execution kind of looks like this. You
know, part of your threads will diverge
based on this if statement. Some of them
will go to the bottom branch, some of
them will go to the top branch. And the
bottom branch ones will execute first,
top branch ones will wait, and then the
top branch ones will execute and the
bottom branch ones will wait, right? So,
in order to execute an if statement,
you're actually sort of clock walking
through both of these, and then some of
the threads are just waiting, doing
nothing, if they're if they're on the
wrong side of the branch. Um and this is
called control divergence. Um and this
is nice in some ways because it
simplifies programming. It's not nice in
that you now have these big compute gaps
where your GPU's doing nothing, right?
Um this is one of the reasons why you
really do not want to write if
statements. Um you know, if you look at
GPU code, like if you have a ReLU,
you'll often find you're like
multiplying with zeros or multiplying
with masks instead of doing like a if
statement where you're updating half,
right? Cuz cuz a multiplication is going
to all kind of go at once and a if
statement might actually have to wait
two clock cycles or something like this,
two operations.
Okay.
So, that's the first thing. But, you
know, that's a sort of separate story
from all this memory stuff, which is
kind of the main narrative or the main
story of this.
Um the first one, which you don't really
have to do too much for, but I think is
one of the most important ones and
hardware-wise I think where Nvidia's
investing the most effort is low
precision computation.
Um and if you look at this plot, I've
brought, you know, Bill Dally back to
the slide. Um
this super exponential growth, where
does this really come from? Um actually
a pretty non-trivial part of this, you
know, is number representations. You
start at FP32, you go to BF16, and then
you go to INT8. You just keep decreasing
the precision of your numbers. And of
course, if you have half the bits, you
have half the bits to move. And so, you
have your memory movement, right? And
so, you've solved the memory bottleneck
for at least a little bit.
Um
you know, this is a dumb example, but
you know, I'm just going to really drill
it in there. You know, let's say I have
a value on a vector of size N. If I'm on
float 32, I need to do one read, right?
To read my number, I need to do one
write after I've computed my value.
That's going to be 4 bytes per
operation, total of 8 bytes for my
memory access. I only have one flop
worth of operation. So, that's 8 bytes
per flop. You know, if I have the
precision, of course, I've halved the
number of bytes per op. I've, you know,
uh halved the number of bytes that I
need to move per flop. Sorry, this is
the inverse of arithmetic intensity. Uh
arithmetic intensity should be reverse
of this.
Right?
Now,
that's a very simple example, but
actually how low precision works in a
modern GPU is actually very complicated
and actually
either very cool or very crazy depending
on how you sort of think about, you
know, how cool things are.
Um so, when you do a matrix multiply,
let's say you have a tensor core that's
operating in lower precision. How does
that actually work in practice?
Well, you're actually not going to keep
everything in low precision. You're
going to downcast before you take your
product. And when you sum up your
partial summons in your matrix multiply,
you're going to do this in full
precision. And then you might emit your
outputs or your your results in FP32.
And part of I think the reason why low
precision is actually kind of a black
art is not because you can just like
decrease precision. Anyone can do that.
Um you have to figure out which of your
operations has to be in which number
format, right? So, you know, matrix
multiplies, maybe both your weights and
activations can be low precision. If I'm
doing a soft max, maybe I need to do
that in FP32. Or if I'm doing an
exponential, maybe that also needs to be
FP32 or maybe I can get away with BF16,
right? So, you know, I think
uh it took several years really to to
get low precision training to be the
state that it is today. And a lot of
that work was, you know, slow,
incremental, empirical work figuring out
which of these operations we can sort of
downcast, how we can downcast them, and
how we can preserve stability of
training while making as much of our
training and and inference uh low
precision as possible.
Um
people have been pushing this further
and further. I think, you know, once you
think about how hard it is to pay for
fast memory, you realize if only I can
cut my precision by another factor of
two, right? Like people really, really
want to do that. Um and so, you know,
FP8, you know, was kind of the the next
frontier, I would say, of low precision.
Um once you get to FP8, there's no
longer a standard canonical format that
everyone uses. Like if you're using um
FP or sorry, 16 bits, you're probably
using BF16, right? For a lot of what
you're doing. But with FPA, there's
going to be E4M3, which stands for
uh four bits of exponent and three of
mantissa, or there's going to be E5M2,
which is more exponent, fewer mantissa,
right? Because these are used in
different places, there's no
one-size-fits-all once you start to get
to so few bits.
But I think the thing that's really
interesting is
uh the more advanced low-precision
number formats that are coming out with
the new hardware. So, I'll talk uh
briefly about MXFP8 because it's both
cool and what it does to training is uh
strange, to say the least. Um so, in
FP8, the traditional version of
training, what you have is that all of
your, let's say, activations are in
eight-bits, right? So, this is up here.
And then you're going to have a scaling
factor in 32, FP32, that's going to
allow you to scale this up and down. Why
do you have a scaling factor? The
scaling factor is necessary because you
only have four bits of exponent, let's
say, right? That's so few bits of
exponent, you're going to quickly over-
or underflow. So, you need the scaling
factor to kind of keep you in the right
right range so you can keep some
information, right?
Um well, people realized um this is not
optimal because a single matrix might
have very different magnitudes, right?
One part of my sequence might have much
bigger sort of activations than another.
So, um instead of having a single
scaling factor, why don't we have many
scaling factors, right? So, MXFP8 and
sort of these multi-scaling factor uh
formats that are sort of much more
advanced now have many scaling factors.
Each of these scaling factors
corresponds to the relevant colored
submatrix, right? So, the first four uh
elements in this matrix corresponds to
this first scaling factor, and so on and
so forth.
Now I have more scaling factors. These
scaling factors are actually going to be
uh in lower precision. These are going
to be eight-bits as well. They're going
to be E8M0, so they only have exponent
bits. So, they're all powers of two, um,
you know, in uh, eight bits.
So, you have to make these tradeoffs.
Now,
um,
well, I was going to say, okay. So,
MXFPA is going to use more mantissa in
the elements, scale factors are
themselves FPA, um, and you're going to
have one scale factor every 32 elements
in your matrix.
Okay, I'm going to pause here. Uh, don't
read the third thing. Now, think for a
moment, what is the problem with this
design? Like, what is the big issue if
you do something as clever as this?
So, the big issue here is, let's say I
want to transpose this matrix. The
transpose of this matrix does not have
the same pattern, so to speak, scaling
pattern as this matrix, right? And so,
now, it used to be that a transpose of a
matrix was simple. I just transpose this
matrix, I don't have to re-quantize, I
don't have to do anything.
Now, transposing this matrix is very
complicated because I now have to
potentially re-quantize this whole
matrix to fit this one out of 32 pattern
that I have.
Um, and so, what happens internally when
you actually use MXFPA, and I found this
to be crazy, but also kind of cool, is
that when you're training your model
with this thing, it actually creates two
copies of every quantized matrix, one
for your original matrix, one for the
transpose. So, if you ever want to
transpose, you have the transposed
version waiting for you, right? Um, and
that's kind of how you get around this,
which I think is a is a crazy and cool
thing.
Um, the point here is maybe not the to
emphasize the GPU trivia, but the point
here is that once you start getting to
these FPA FP4 formats, things start
getting pretty exotic cuz the amount of
exponent and and sort of mantissa loss
that you have are pretty extreme. So,
you have to be very clever about how you
do this. Um, and as I said, you know, if
you were to go and really train a model
FPA, which I think a lot of frontier
labs are doing for the compute benefits,
um,
you know, you have to be very careful,
right? Um,
this plot does show kind of what what
saying. So, every time you quantize,
you're going to quantize one way and
you're going to transpose and quantize,
so you're going to have both copies. And
then the other part, which I told you
about a few slides ago, is you're only
going to quantize certain layers that
you think are safe to do so, right? And
this is another trial and error thing
that you have to figure out, right? Um
but once you have all this together, you
have the big benefits of training in
FP8, which is that when you're doing
those matrix multiplies, you're probably
going to get 20 to 30% savings, maybe
more, depending on the size of your
matrix. Um unfortunately, it's not going
to be a 2x speed up because you have to
do all these quantization operations,
right? There's a big overhead doing
this, so it's not free. Yes.
>> So, remember the thing
like reading that like
the first layer and the last layer are
hard to quantize. Do you have any
intuition about that?
>> That's right. That's right.
I don't know if I have intuitions for
the first layer. The last layer, I think
being hard to quantize is because, you
know, it is kind of a first-order
factor. It derives a ton of the loss.
And so, I think you end up getting like
both instability and big loss in uh
increases if you attempt to quantize the
very last layer.
Okay. Um I put this up here almost
because I think it's so ridiculous. You
know, the next frontier, this is already
implemented as MXFP4. Um the entirety of
MXFP4 can be shown to you in this slide.
It's
negative six to six. You know, you you
have all the possible values.
Um but now that you understand MXFPA,
you can also understand how this thing
works. You know, you're going to have a
structured block where each block is
going to be one of these four bits. Um
you're going to have uh every 16 of
these numbers, you're going to have one
scaling factor, and that scaling factor
will itself be uh FPA. This is a E4M3
scaling uh for those scaling factors.
Um these are
There has been a paper that has trained
with FP4. I don't think I've heard of
anyone successfully training in the
wild, you know, real big serious models
with FP4.
Um but I think this is coming, right?
Like the next generation of models will
probably be FP4.
Okay. So, that was low precision. I
think it's really cool that you can
really push the limits so far that, you
know, you're ending up with just plus
six to minus six and yet you can do
interesting things with matrices in that
precision.
Now, oh yeah, is there a question?
>> So,
is this only for
like matrices that you can apply this?
Like not the single scalar values.
>> Yeah, so you can you can quantize
anything. You can quantize the
activations after a ReLU, for example,
but there just isn't as much of a of a
need to. So, like a matmul, if you
quantize that, you can get really big
throughput improvements, right? And
that's why if you look at the MXFP8
training one, you know, these are all
matmuls that are getting FP8 quantized.
Um the overhead is probably not worth it
for for most of the time.
>> It has to do with like the hardware
It's not like the
matmul hardware part only does this.
>> Well, it's not exclusive to that. Yeah,
like you you can always do lower
precision stuff and then it will
decrease your memory movement. This is
true. But for the others, it doesn't
quite make sense.
>> This isn't any like like hardware
limitation.
>> It's not a limitation, but there is
hardware support for all of this, right?
So, there is baked in a bunch of this is
baked into the hardware to accelerate
it. Um yeah.
>> And you position this as a
as an improvement for memory bandwidth
or well
requiring less memory bandwidth, but is
there a
a bandwidth to compute as well?
>> Yes, yes, for sure. For compute, you get
basically linear improvements for just
multiplying the quantized numbers.
But the fact that you have to quantize
and dequantize means that the benefits
are more diluted.
Yeah.
>> Do you have to train the scaling factor?
>> Uh the scaling factor is an
implementation-dependent choice. Like
depending on the library, for example,
you might get different ways of
quantizing and dequantizing. Um
training is a is a strong word, but you
might have quantization factors that
like scan through and pick the max and
min, or you might have scaling factors
that look at historical running
statistics and then use those. I
wouldn't really call them training per
se. Um at inference you might fit them
more
>> So there's no gradients.
>> At inference time you might. Um at
training time you would not.
Yeah.
>> And just to clarify, has anything been
done with structured sparsity? Like
Yeah. Cuz like I said we didn't add it
but
>> Yeah, there's a lot that's been done
with structured sparsity and I mean MOEs
are I think one successful example of a
structured sparse operation that people
use.
>> What about like sparse ones?
>> Yeah, right. So I mean a lot has been
done. Chris Ray here has done a lot
with, you know, lots of different kinds
of structured matrices.
Um I think the benefits of that, like,
you know, in terms of the compute
benefits versus the representation
losses, I think has kind of washed out.
Um I don't think it's a bad idea but
empirically it hasn't, I think,
necessarily panned out.
Oh, yeah.
>> A lot of like things like squeeze that
we didn't talk about on that slide.
What is current state of the art
approach? Is it like train in full net
or half net and then like distill into
like quantize model that you can run on
your Apple computer or things like that?
Like what what is like state of the art?
>> Yeah, I mean there's a combination of
like you probably want to train a bigger
model and then quantize down.
Um there's various kinds of like
quantization scaling laws and and papers
that people have written like precisely
characterizing the the trade-offs here.
Um I think the state of the art involves
combining both like quantization aware
training to some extent and like model
scaling with um post-training
quantization of various kinds. Like,
yeah.
Um
there's a lot that I think is not fully
well understood. Um even industry teams
that I've talked to are sort of talking
about still doing like science of
quantization. So
Yeah. Okay. So the other trick, um this
one is much more of like a conceptual
programming thing, um is operator
fusion. It's it's fairly simple idea but
you'll be surprised at like how much
this doesn't already happen.
Um so think of a GPU as a factory.
You've got your memory warehouse, and
you've got your little compute factory,
and you've got a little belt conveyor
going back and forth, right? Um,
if you scale up your compute, you're
going to be bottlenecked by your little
belt conveyor. And this will be worse if
you have many operations, right? Like
imagine I've got lots of different
operations I need to do, and I'm going
to ship my, you know, raw materials to
my factory and back and forth and back
and forth. This is a lot of memory
bottleneck that you're paying for,
right? And lots of sort of duplex
bidirectional memory bandwidth. Now,
wouldn't it be better if I just had a
one giant factory that would take all
the raw materials and ship back my
finished products, right? Um, this way I
only have to pay for memory bandwidth
twice. Very sim- very simple idea. This
is operator fusion, right? Um,
and this appears very often, right? If
you write a very simple, um, let's say
computation of sine squared plus cosine
squared, what does the PyTorch
computation graph look like? It looks
like this. You got your X, I do my sine,
I do my cosine, I square it on both
sides, I add them, and then I get my
output, right? Um,
naively, if you don't do anything smart,
what this will do is each of these will
be a factory, so to speak, right? You
will read and write from global memory
each one of each time one of these is
called, right? Um, and you will incur
quite a bit of memory cost every time
you do so. So, this is pretty painful.
Um, and you can imagine, instead of
doing that, why don't I just write GPU
code that reads once from global memory,
does the whole thing, right? Inside the
inside the the SM as I talked about
before, and then after it's done inside
the SM I'm going to write it back to
global memory, right? A single sort of
kernel uh that does all of these
operations. This is called fusion,
right? Um, and anything that's easy like
this, like this is a very easy fusion.
It's like a graph that I can sort of
just, you know, squish down into a
single unit, um,
a compiler can automatically do this for
you. So, Torch Compile, which is a
compiler for PyTorch, or JAX Compile,
which is, you know, JAX's compiler,
which is more deeply integrated into
Jax. Both of these will fuse these kinds
of basic things into a single CUDA call.
Um
I'll talk a little bit more about
fusion later, but I think this is, you
know, the advanced version sometimes
requires sort of manual intervention,
but the simple versions you can just
think of as, you know, compilation will
solve your problems.
Okay, the third idea is re-computation.
So, we know in backpropagation, what
what do we do? Well, we go forwards up
up on the tree. This is from Percy's 221
class. You know, you go upwards on the
tree and you keep track of activations,
right? You store these little activation
numbers and then when I go backwards,
I'm going to use the activations that I
stored to compute sort of the backwards
signal down my my tree, right? We all
know backprop some extent, so, you know,
we know what this is.
But also, now, you know, we're looking
at this not from the perspective of like
mathematics, how do we compute a
gradient? We're thinking about this from
the perspective of systems, right? Like
how do we minimize our memory?
Well, if we think about what's
happening, let's say I have something
simple. I have X sigmoid sigmoid sigmoid
out, right? Each of these sigmoids is
going to generate in the computation
graph some sort of residual, right? Or
some sort of a activation that I need to
to track. So, I I after my first
operation, I have S2, second operation
S1, and then when I need to do my
backwards pass, it will consume S2, S1
and my output or sorry, the gradient at
my output and I'm going to push this
backwards towards the the derivative of
my input, right? So, if I count the
number of memory reads and writes, it's
going to be one memory read for X, three
memory writes for S2, S1 out, and then
on the backwards pass, this is sort of
flipped, right? So, this is a total of
eight memory reads and writes, um very
low arithmetic intensity cuz I'm just
stacking a bunch of sigmoids.
Now,
what can I do instead? Well, what I can
do is I can just throw away all of the
activations. Normally, you wouldn't do
this, right? Like why would I want to
recompute something? But imagine you're
in a world where computation is super
super cheap. You just have abundant
computation. You're not using all of
your units, but your memory is very
expensive. Like any read and write has a
lot of penalty. Then you might prefer
this computation graph where I read an X
and then I'm going to do sigmoid sigmoid
sigmoid output. I'm going to store this
output. I have to write this cuz that's
the the output of my graph. But now in
the backwards pass, right? My backwards
graph is going to get in D out and sort
of on the fly, I'm going to re-forward
the X and then compute the activations
on the fly right where I need them,
right? So now this is going to be two
memory reads for the D out and the X and
one memory right for the DX, right? So
I've gone from eight total memory
accesses to just five, right? So now I
have 5/8 the total memory accesses. Same
computation, but I've spent a little bit
of extra compute and saved a little bit
of extra memory, right? This is the
another very important trick. We don't
normally think about this because
usually we're concerned with like just
computing the gradient, but once you
have a system's mindset, you start to to
think about recomputation.
Cool.
Okay.
Trick number four, um this is another
sort of memory trivia thing, but
surprisingly becomes important. Um and
also why sometimes it's important to
understand the hardware model of what
you are you're interacting with.
Um
so global memory, which you know, is the
big memory that lives outside the the
chip, um is DRAM and DRAM, uh because of
the way that it is structured,
um
actually comes in bursts. What that
means is when I access, let's say the
very first position, I don't actually
get the just the first value. I can read
off all four of these first values for
free. And that's because the way the
memory cells are lined up, there's kind
of these blocks of memory units and then
when I sort of activate an amplifier, I
can just read out all of these almost
for free, right? The way that it's sort
of structured in parallel allows me to
read blocks of memory. That kind of
makes sense, right, as a hardware model.
Um and so this is called a burst
section. And so whenever a section is
accessed, all the other locations can
also get delivered for free, right? And
you won't pay for them, so to speak. Um
and so, you know, you might have
something like 128 bytes worth of a
burst. That means a single read will
return potentially 128 bytes worth of
data as long as it lives in the same
contiguous block.
So this means that if you have your
reads arranged contiguously where
they're all together,
it's going to go much faster.
Um and to use a term, um you say that a
memory access is coalesced. So So that
word means if all of the threads in a
warp fall in the same burst. So what
that means is, let's say I have, you
know, three threads and all three of my
thread or sorry, four threads. Wait,
four threads. And my four threads uh
live inside of a single burst section,
right? Or they're reading from this
burst section. Then this is coalesced,
right? Um because they're sort of using
up all of this entire burst section, um
and I'm fully utilizing this very nice
property of DRAM memory. Um and, you
know, uh so if I have, you know,
multiple warps, you know, I'm going to
have different multiple burst sections,
but you can efficiently read out of
memory by sort of grouping together your
memory reads.
Um why don't Oh, yeah.
>> This sort of just explained it. Why Why
does this Why does this
balance like this? This sort of makes
sense coming
>> Which one? Like this?
>> Like this one? Yeah.
>> Yeah. So So, um
as far as I understand, you know, the
memory cells are arranged in a grid and
your amplifiers for like deciding which
cells to read sort of operate at a
column-wise level. And like activating
the voltage for this is often a thing
that takes a significant amount of time.
So once you've like selected the column,
readouts of multiple elements within
that column are much comparatively
cheaper.
>> This is This is to like select to to
read that
upper upper left cell, right? Or
>> Or yeah, right. So if I want to read
this, for example, right, like, you
know, I'm sorting this, or maybe it's
the columns that are cheap in this
diagram, at least. But, you know, if I'm
trying to read this, you know, I might
get this whole row for free, right?
Because I've addressed this whole row.
>> Okay, so I don't get a key for free, I
just
>> You don't get a key for free, yeah.
Okay, good.
Okay.
Um, okay, so so you're saying like,
Tatsu, why are you telling me uh DRAM
trivia? Um, the reason I'm telling you
DRAM trivia is because, you know, think
about matrices, right? Matrices you
often want to read in big blocks, right?
Because you're going to do matmuls.
And certain kinds of memory accesses on
matmuls are sort of privileged. They're
they're much more nicely structured than
others. And sometimes you can take
advantage of this to get very, very fast
memory reads. So, uh the the mnemonic,
or, you know, the thing that I remember
is, if you have threads, and you have a
row major matrix, so if, you know, it's
sorted where, you know, each row is sort
of how you your indexes are increasing,
um, threads that move along the major
axis are not coalesced. And to to really
make make this visual, actually, I I
like this diagram on the right. Imagine
I have this 4x4 matrix, where this is
row major, so it's sorted in the order
uh of, you know, the yellow block comes
first, the red block comes next, and so
on and so forth. This is the linear
ordering, uh sort of in memory address.
This is kind of the matrix that, you
know, I'm trying to store.
Now, imagine that I have threads that
are trying to read um each column, each
clock cycle. So, I read a column, I move
to the right, I read a column, I move to
the right. If I'm doing that, at the
very first iteration, I hit this
element, this element, this element,
this element. Notice that each one of
these limit a different burst window,
and I read the entire vector, so to
speak, right? Or the entire matrix,
sorry, so to speak, even though all I
wanted was a single column, right? Now,
imagine if I was reversed, if I was
flipping this matrix, I could read the
entire sort of block. Every thread would
get its read in a single sort of read of
the memory, right? Um
So, coalescing can give you significant
improvements in sort of reads from large
contiguous uh structures like matrices.
So, this is one reason why you might
want to think a little bit about row
versus column versus uh other kinds of
ordering.
Okay.
Um the last one that I want to talk
about, and this is the big one, um and
maybe the most important idea, I've like
saved it for last, is the idea of
tiling. And I think this one has
probably the the big impact on
performance.
Um
Tiling, I think more than any other
idea, is this idea of trying to do as
much as you can with the memory
hierarchy. So, what we want to do is we
want to group our memory accesses as
much as possible, and sort of shared
memory accesses should be done together,
and they should be done on shared
memory. So, the way that we the reason
why it's called tiling is I'm going to
cut up the things that I need, I'm going
to tile my space, and each tile will be
loaded into my shared memory. And once
that tile is loaded, I'm going to
repeatedly read from that tile and do as
much as I can. So, let's think about the
matrix multiply case. I want to
multiply, you know, this matrix and this
matrix, and this uh matrix on the right
bottom, this is my output, right? This
is sort of where I'm writing my matrix
out. This is a pretty standard notation
for this.
Um
Now, if I want to do this, right? Uh I'm
going to be reading, you know, as I'm
reading through the threads, multiple uh
sorry, the same entry will be read
multiple times. And to be precise, each
entry will be read n times uh in a n by
n matrix multiply, right? Naively.
Um so, you might think, right? If I'm
reading this entry, let's say m0,
multiple times, instead of hitting
global memory each time, why can't I
sort of group all of those memory
accesses together?
And the nice thing about matrices is
that there's a very natural grouping,
right? Um and this is to essentially cut
the matrix up into submatrices, and then
load them and then operate upon them,
right? So, here is a very simple
algorithm. I'm going to cut up my
matrices into sort of 2 by 2, you know,
submatrices. And then I'm going to load
different tiles. So, I'm going to first
load the M00 tile, the top left here.
I'm going to load the N00 tile, the top
left of my top matrix. And I'm going to
load those into shared memory, right?
So, I'm going to pay the cost of
transferring those slowly from global
memory once. But once they're in shared
memory, I can read and write very fast
with those tiles, right? This output
tile will also be for now in shared
memory and I will operate on these
submatrices entirely, right? So, I'll
multiply these two submatrices and I'll
put the partial sum into my output
submatrix. So, that allows me to to do a
bunch of reads and writes all in the
shared fast memory and then I can write
it back out when I'm done.
Um what does the math look like? Well,
in the non-tiled case, I already told
you, right? Each element of my input is
going to have to be read n times when I
do this big n by n matrix multiply.
Um if I tile them with a tile size of T,
then each input is going to be read n
over T times from global memory and then
T times within each tile, right? And
this kind of makes sense, the extreme,
right? If T is equal to n, I read it
once from global memory and access it n
times in in shared memory, right? And
this is great because it's a T times
reduction in global memory access. If
you have big big shared memory tiles, it
means that you can dramatically reduce
your global memory access on something
like a map mole.
Um
cool.
Tiling okay, yes.
>> So, are you doing this because you can't
update the entire matrix?
>> Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. That's right. Yeah,
but you know, if you were
building one of these like uh
very fancy alternative accelerator like
Rock or something which is all SRAM,
then yeah, you just put the whole matrix
in there and you're very fast with the
whole thing. But very expensive, very
very expensive. Yeah.
>> And then this also happens
[clears throat] with map mole.
There's a couple of tiles
that are like I can't even care.
useless.
So like and then you just keep adding
that cell again and again.
Is that kind of how it
>> You you mean like are you asking whether
this kind of like splitting happens at
like the accelerator level for
>> Yeah.
>> That's right.
That's right. Yeah. So so data parallel
you can think of as this like that's
you know if I have data on this axis and
weights here if I cut it on one of the
axes that's kind of data tensor parallel
could be another kind of parallelism.
All these parallelism look a little bit
like tiling in some ways. Yeah.
Cool. Okay.
Oh yeah.
>> Yeah. But but super descriptive on the
previous one. Can I assume that
you know library like PyTorch will just
do that automatically?
>> Tiling yes yes yes yeah. So like any
like matmul kernel that you call will do
tiling underneath. Yeah. That's right.
If you're doing some sort of exotic
operation you might want to think about
tiling like things happening right? You
want to be able to locally reuse your
your
reads.
Um
but I will say
even PyTorch or something is not perfect
and so you know we will talk about some
of the imperfections that will happen.
Um so tiling is very very powerful as an
idea but it's also complex. You can
actually end up with some like really
subtle things happening with tiles. So
imagine I have a tile size of 128 128.
You know if my matrices are 256 by 256
life is good. I've got four tiles right?
Perfectly cut. Now imagine I increase my
coordinate size by one right? Now I've
generated two very skinny tiles with
basically nothing inside of them right?
So now you kind of realize you know
actually this tile sizing tile sizing
thing is actually pretty complex.
Depending on my matrices I might need to
adjust my tile sizes to somehow you know
trade off my memory bandwidth versus you
know this gigantic empty space where I'm
doing nothing right? Um,
so, you know, you have to tile sizes is
is actually a thing that you optimize.
So, like coalesced memory accesses, the
size of your shared memory on your
accelerator, and the sizes of your
matrices all affect, you know, which
tiles are optimal.
And, um, if you know about different
options in PyTorch, you know, there's a
compiler option called max auto tune. I
don't know how many of you have used
this or know about this. You know, you
turn on that flag, for the next 15
minutes PyTorch is going to like, you
know, run a endless series of
benchmarking tests. And you'll realize
actually what it's doing is it's like
trying all sorts of different tile sizes
on your matrices and trying to figure
out which one is actually faster. Um,
and you'll find that you'll get, you
know, non-trivial benefits from actually
optimizing these things.
Um,
the other thing that you'll find,
related to coalescing, is if your tiles,
uh, or if your matrices are the wrong
size, what you can do is that your
attempt to read a tile might actually
trigger a lot of memory reads. So,
imagine I I have this nice world where,
you know, I have, uh, let's say this
blue one is the row, and I want to read
this nice tile, and my burst sections
are sort of the width of the tile. In
this case, if I do sort of four reads,
you know, I'm good to go because because
of the burst sections, I read this
entire submatrix, right? So, good memory
read from coalescing.
Now, imagine I shift the matrix size by
one. Now I've bumped this first row
over, so this blue box now lives over
here, um, and there's no way for me to
coalesce my reads to read a single tile
in one go, right? Because now all these
things are sort of ragged and
misaligned. So, I need to do at least
two tiles worth of reads to read out
this one tile, right? So, you know,
there's actually a lot of complexities
involved in optimizing tile reads once
you start thinking about coalescing and
all these other things. And so, in this
case, what you have to do is padding in
order to line up essentially the the
boundaries of the burst sections, um,
with, uh, the tile sizes that you have.
Okay.
Um, and this is why you end up getting
stuff like this, which seems very
mysterious. Um, I think this is one of
my favorite weird ones. Right, Andrej
Karpathy when he was doing nanoGPT speed
run said, "Well, you know, when I
increase my vocab size to 5257 to 5304,
um, you know, I got a 25% speed up,
right?"
Um, and it's kind of weird to have to
pad in order to get a speed up, but
maybe it makes sense once you realize
things like this, right? Padding can
start to shift the the rows and columns
so that you actually get very efficient
reads, whereas at other times you do
not. Um, yes, go ahead.
>> Is there a Is there a Google
Do you have like tile sizes that you
should be taking into account?
>> You don't want to think about tile sizes
per se because tiles you should normally
think of as like a lower-level systems
thing, unless you're writing your own
kernels. But you do want to think about
the size of your matrices.
>> Okay, but you want your size of your of
your matrices to be divisible by the
tile size?
>> You want to be Right, so so you want it
to be I'll talk about that in a moment,
but Right, generally powers of two,
ideally divisible also by like 32.
Right. Okay, so now we can talk about
this matrix mystery over here.
Um, we have essentially all of the
pieces that we need to understand this,
so we'll walk through this, um, one by
one. Um, we've already talked about
compute intensity, right? The roofline
plot. You need to have enough work for
each memory read in order for you to be
able to saturate your compute unit.
That's what's driving the sort of
diagonal upward trend, so that one is
done. Now, let's talk about some of the
other ones. First one is tiling, right?
Um, if we look at each of these lines
and we color them based on, um,
essentially the the divisibility, uh, of
the matrices, you will find that, you
know, the blue ones are essentially only
divisible by one. They're not even divi-
They're not even even. Um, yellow ones
are so orange ones are divisible by two,
right? Um, green is divisible by eight.
Uh, k- red is 16, and and purple is 32.
And you see, you know, that the ones
that are not divisible by, you know, one
or just one or just two actually have
very bad throughput.
But once you start to get to sort of
higher multiples, you start to
essentially get no sort of diminishing
or sorry, no uh penalties, right? Like
16 or 32 perform equally well. And this
is really it's not because of like
somehow powers of two are magic or
something like that. It's because 16 and
32 are sufficiently large that it has
the right sort of burst window property.
It sort of fits the whole burst window
in now. And so you can get coalesced
reads into your entire tile. And it has
a major impact on alignment. Um
Now, if we look at sort of what's
remaining, if we look at this orange
line, we'll sometimes see this weird
periodic behavior where suddenly
performance will drop, right? And this
is very weird because I'm just
multiplying matrices. Why does adding a
single extra dimension suddenly kill my
throughput? Um and this is, you know, I
think using all of the things that we
learned is kind of fun to to to get to
this end. Um Percy calls this uh GPU
trivia. So I think he hates but I love
this one. Um so why is it that going
from here to here I get such a big drop
in throughput? Well, um it happens
between 1792 to 1793.
Um and why does this happen? Well, I'm
using a tile size of 256 by 128. So that
means how many tiles are there? Well,
there's 98 at 1792. But once I bump
myself up to 1793,
well, actually I've increased both tile
sizes by one. So I now have 120 tiles.
Okay, so I have 98 tiles before and I
have 120 tiles now.
That's bad, but it's not this bad,
right? This drop is gigantic. Well,
turns out the reason why it's so
dramatic is because the A100 has 108
SMs, right? And 98 tiles fits in 108
SMs, but 120 tiles does not fit in 108
SMs, right? And so you you finish doing
108 SMs and you're like, well, I've got
12 more of these guys. I got to I guess
process them and most of your your GPU
sitting idle, right? So, you can end up
with these very weird effects once again
where, you know, by bumping up your tile
size by one, suddenly you need to wait a
whole 'nother cycle for you to process a
bunch of tiles, right?
Um that's called wave quantization.
Okay, so that was all for for part two.
Um how do we make machine learning
workloads go fast on a GPU? Well, a lot
of the story is really just about memory
memory memory memory, right? So, how do
we reduce the amount of memory access we
have to do? Well, let's coalesce our
memory reads together. Let's fuse our
operations together so we don't have to
read as much. And for the things that we
have to read no matter what, well, let's
reuse the memory, right? So, shared
memory uh move things to shared memory
and reuse it as much as possible, which
is tiling. And then finally, maybe you
can trade other resources that you have
for memory and that's quantization and
recomputation, right? Like so, all these
ideas um pretty much relate to this idea
of like memory is our bottleneck, how do
we deal with that, right?
Cool. Okay.
Um any questions for the last
finishing. Yeah.
>> I feel like this bump up the SRAM
is very expensive to do that for
>> Very expensive. Very energy I mean,
there there's two reasons. One is it's,
you know, just expensive to build SRAM.
Also, very difficult cuz it has to be
physically close, like, you know, signal
propagation is hard. And I think a third
reason is that SRAM and DRAM are just
kind of different storage mechanisms.
Like SRAM needs to be powered the whole
time to hold value, very energy hungry.
And so, you know, if you're thinking
about total cost of ownership, energy
consumption, maybe you don't want a
giant SRAM chip. You really want to be
using it where you need it.
Yes.
>> Does SRAM
for those things scale up past like 32
or like
like if you like operate in chunks of
like 64?
>> You mean like does it help if I go
higher? No, because I think, you know,
this is really it's kind of like a as
long as it divides by your birth size
then you're good to go, right? It's a
divisor property. Um there are other
phenomena where you might get benefits
from, you know, larger divisors but not
not here.
Uh yes.
>> Why 108 [snorts] birth?
>> That's just the number of SMs. You will
have to ask Jensen for that. I do not
have an answer for you. Yes.
>> Um so,
you're
going back to the to the hardware side,
sorry. Uh not this related but uh I it
just occurred in my mind. Have you
studied uh
GPU uh versus uh single versus wafer
scale engine?
>> Yeah, I mean, I think
sitting over there knows much more about
wafer scale stuff than I do. We were we
were talking about last you know, after
last lecture how difficult the
compilation was cuz if you have
something wafer scale, then you have
like wave interference effects and all
sorts of horrible things that happen.
That's a world that I'm not familiar
with but I think it's much more
complicated than what we have here.
Okay, cool. All right, so now I think we
can talk about uh in some sense the
finale, uh which is we've learned a
bunch of things about GPUs. It would be
nice if we can tie that all together to
essentially be able to reproduce or
understand something that I think is
really important in advance, which is
flash attention, okay? So, flash
attention is one of the big, I think,
improvements in attention capabilities
in a while and it's all systems, right?
So, it's going from just PyTorch's naive
implementation of attention to a single
very cleverly fused kernel, um you know,
this is from the original paper but
you've got this dramatic improvement in
the latency uh of serving these things.
And as I showed you in uh I think two
lectures ago, right, flash attention is
is a nice memory efficient way of
computing things. So, you can do bigger
and bigger
attention. And you can see, you know, a
lot of the gains are going to come from
um
uh improvements in the amount of memory
that is transferred from HBM, which is
the the global memory, right?
Okay, so what what do they actually do?
If you read the paper, you know, they'll
say, "Okay, we we just do two things. We
apply tiling and re-computation, right?
And then we do it in a way that allows
us to do things sub-quadratically in the
number of memory accesses." I think we
understand all of those components now,
so let's see what's actually happening.
So, remember attention computation,
right? Has
couple things. It has that K Q V, and we
do a, you know, multip- matrix multiply
with the K's and the Q's, and then we
have a matrix multiply with a V at the
end, and have a softmax in the middle,
right? So, those are the operations that
we need to deal with. Three matrix
multiplies and one softmax.
So, we have matrix multiplies. We know
how to do them now, right? So, we're
going to do a tiled matrix multiply. Um
figure one from the paper is literally
just tiled matrix multiplies, right?
We've seen this before. We're taking our
inputs, uh our K's and Q's, we're
cutting them up, and we're just
multiplying them sort of chunk by chunk
on a tile, and then after we do the
computation, we write them out. Nothing
fancy or special here. The thing that is
tricky about uh flash attention, and
you'll see this in the assignment, is
there's a big global softmax on the
whole thing, right? So, we can't just do
this naively because the softmax is a
global operation that ties everyone
together, right? [snorts] So, it
connects all of the different tiles
together. It might not seem obvious how
to tile uh attention.
The key trick, and once you see this,
this is really the the core, I guess,
idea or observation. Once you see this,
the rest is very simple. Normally, to
compute a softmax, you would do it kind
of this way, as shown in this uh
plot here,
which is you would exponentiate all of
your elements, you would subtract the
maximum for numerical stability reasons,
and then you would normalize that,
right? Standard softmax. Now, there's a
different way of computing this online,
and I think once you sort of realize it,
it's kind of simple, which is you're
going to sort of, as you go, compute the
normalized softmax. And every time you
encounter a bigger number than what
you've seen before, you're going to sort
of swap out the maximum, right? Um and
so, you have a online way of computing
sort of the soft max as you go. The only
tricky thing of course being the max.
And the way we deal with the max is we
keep track of the max, and then we sort
of swap it out and correct for it every
time we see a new maximum. Otherwise,
this is really just a online running sum
of an exponential
from everything that we've we've seen
before. And of course at the end, you'll
just divide everything by the
accumulator that you've computed online.
Now the important thing about the online
soft max is because it's online and it
goes kind of block by block or or piece
by piece, we can compute this tile by
tile, right? I don't need to see the
rest of the tiles in order to compute
this. So I can compute the soft max for
my tile, and then I can sort of save the
partial results, maybe write them back
to global memory,
and then just sort of continue on with
my day. So this allows us to now break
up sort of all the different interacting
pieces into something simpler.
So this I think is a
I think this was from flash attention
two or maybe three. I think it's two.
I like this visualization which shows
you, you know, which parts are being
tiled. So the dashed blocks are being
done tiled in SRAM. The blue boxes are
the ones that are in high bandwidth
memory, the global memory. And what you
see is let's say we do the KQ, you know,
inner product. You know, these are tiled
matrix multiplies and they're stored in
SRAM. And we keep them in the SRAM, and
we compute this exponential. And then
similarly, in this tile, we're going to
compute this running soft max. And I'm
going to move to my next tile, and I'm
going to do the same thing. But now I'm
going to keep sort of the partial
running sums of my soft max as I go. I
can keep them sort of in shared memory
or in registers or elsewhere. This is a
very small number of things to keep
track of. At the end, after I've
computed all these exponentiated
quantities and my normalizers, it's very
simple to just multiply it with a V,
once again in the tiled form, and then
divide at the very end, right? This
allows me to essentially take the
attention operation, cut it up into
these small tiled chunks,
and then go.
Finally,
you've got a You're going to do both of
these together, right? As much as you
can without going back and forth. Um and
then I'm not going to cover this or talk
about it, uh but what you can do is you
can um in the backward pass recompute
everything that you need, right? So, the
the last piece of of uh flash attention
is if you saved your activations, you
still have this n squared sized
activation that you're going to need to
save for your attention. Instead of
saving that, throw it all away and
recompute everything tile by tile on the
backward pass, right? So, it's got the
recomputation piece as well.
Okay. That gives you flash attention.
Now, we've seen all of the different
tricks in action.
Um and that's essentially all there is,
right? A lot of the tricks that you see
for for efficient implementation and how
to use GPUs well boil down to those
kinds of ideas.
So, to put it all back together, right?
Important to understand the hardware.
The hardware, in in our case the GPU, is
powering scale and compute and we need
to understand really all the way to the
low-level details to to fully grasp why
we make certain decisions. Like I think,
you know, I don't want you guys to to be
the the kind of people that cargo cult,
you know, 32 multipliers for your
matrices. I want you to really
understand, you know, why we do those
things and that goes all the way down in
my opinion to the hardware level.
Um the other thing is that, you know,
the current, you know, way that compute
is growing means that we really want to
think about matmuls. Those are the core
operations that are very arithmetically
dense. And because of the the gap
between compute and memory, we need to
think very carefully about data
movement, right? And then finally, um
things like flash attention I think are
really cool. There's also like
architecture work that's like very
hardware aware. Um thinking carefully
about the hardware when we do things
like architecture design is, you know,
critical to good performance for future
systems. Um thanks.